Let's be honest, your contribution to
the world so far is a browser history
you make sure no one sees. Incognito
tabs, deleted logs, hours gone, nothing
built. Now, contrast that with this. A
masjid is being completed in a village
in Norway where Muslims have nothing. It
will stand for generations. Those who
donate will be remembered by Allah. And
those who don't will quietly return to
the shadows, back to the consumption,
secrecy, and absolute nothing to show
for it. So, do the right thing. Post the
video or click the link below and donate
for your own akhira.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. How are you guys doing?
The hillbilly president. The accused
pedophile president.
The accused rapist president.
The Epstein's friend president. The
trailer hillbilly president. I think I
mentioned that already. You did. Yeah.
But I think it's worth mentioning twice.
Well, you know what? I watched this
video, man, of Trump coming out and and
actually essentially saying that, you
know, we we came to a resolution
with Iran and the war is going to end.
Let's take a look at this clip and
respond in kind.
>> What about the straight of Hormuz? Who's
going to be in control of that?
>> That'll be opened up very soon if this
works.
>> How soon?
And who's going to control that?
>> Well, Iran's going to be able to control
the flow of oil?
>> be jointly controlled.
By who?
Maybe me.
>> Not the United States of America?
>> ME AND THE AYATOLLAH.
UNITED STATES ME AND THE AYATOLLAH.
>> ME AND THE AYATOLLAH. So now we adding
another word, the weak president,
the coward president, the one who said
he was the anti-war president ended up
being the war president and couldn't
even do that properly. He lost. He lost.
But do you do you know what? I mean,
this even if this is some kind of a
strategy of war or something or he he
pretends that it is Mhm. This is
humiliation, bro. Yeah. This is so bad.
He's coming out and he's basically
saying, "Yeah, we've come to an
agreement and these kind But I came
across this video from Jeffrey Sachs,
yeah, who's a professor and an econo-
economist, I think Columbia University
in America. Actually, his takes on this
this war are worth listening to. Um I'm
not sure if you watched the judge uh
this guy called judge um I forget his
name now.
>> Judge Dredd?
No. No. No, but he's he brings on like
um Scott Ritter, he brings on like, you
know, John John Mearsheimer. Like, you
know what I mean? Like, he brings on the
the the high academics on this
um and professionals and and military
experts and stuff on this war.
And he brought on this this economist
called um
Well, let me just say his name was
>> Jeffrey Sachs. Yeah, Jeffrey Sachs,
right?
And uh this is what Jeffrey Sachs had to
say in response to this video. Let's
take a look at this.
We have had very, very strong
talks. We'll see where they lead. We
have
points of major points of agreement. I
would say almost all points of
agreement. It is impossible that there
has been a resolution of major issues. I
think we have to consider
the possibility that the president has
really
lost touch with reality.
This this is an academic
>> reality. Yeah, this is an academic using
the most passive
neutral language that he can with and he
still couldn't help but use language
like that. Lost reality Lost absolute
reality.
Absolutely. In another
>> basically. Yeah, look
>> mentally sound, he goes on to say. In In
another video, he's saying, "You know
what? We We won the war. It's It's done.
It's finished."
>> of Hormuz, he goes, "The Strait of
Hormuz, uh what do you call it? What Me
and the Ayatollah going to
Let's take a look at the video. It's
hilarious.
Him and the Ayatollah, and apparently
they're solid guys.
The Ayatollah and
they're solid guys now.
>> you won the war, though. I thought the
war was done. I thought you were going
>> part of the regime? He said the regime
changed because the regime because now
the son has taken over from his father.
That's Is this Is this something you're
trying to sell the public?
Bro, it's The whole thing has become a
caricature. It's become a cartoon. It's
become a sitcom comedy. Why? Because on
the one hand, he's saying, "You know
what? It's a very detailed and very
difficult chess game. They're very high
IQ people, and they're making very high
IQ moves." On the other hand, "Oh, you
know what? We're going to rule it
together." If you've won the war, if
you've gone in there to remove the
regime, if you want to liberate them,
why the hell are you co-running the most
of one of the most vital straits on the
planet?
>> Mhm. Well, I think you know what it is
now, like um in the In the '50s
there was a Suez
um Suez Canal crisis, right, in Egypt.
And uh at that time, cuz it was
post-World War II,
um actually the United States had
emerged as a superpower, but hadn't
globally dominated all areas of the
world.
And
the uh United Kingdom at the time had,
um you know, some grip on the Middle
East.
>> Mhm. And it was the Suez uh Canal crisis
that actually shifted the balance of
power
internationally from, like, say, for
example, UK-dominated
system to
uh more more easily crystallizing like
the United States as as one of the main
contenders now. Mhm. Um and this looks
like it's happening again.
The Strait of Hormuz, what's happening
with that and the Iran war,
uh which now it seems like the United
States is going to for all intents and
purposes lose the war Mhm. by the
consensus of everybody who's analyzing
this. Even Trump himself, apparently.
Yeah, cuz the Ayatollah is going to do
to to to rule Me and my good friend the
Ayatollah. They've spent billions of
pounds. Like each day a billion, I think
on average The Economist said.
That's how much they're spending on the
interceptors, and that's how much
they're spending on the missiles, and
you know, just to power the the fighter
jets and everything. We're talking about
a billion a day, and this how many days
I don't know how many days it's been,
but it's moving into a a significant
bill. And that's just for the United
States.
>> And that's just money. They're losing,
Trump's losing a billion a day even in
terms of MAGA supporters as well. If you
look at who's actually left
>> Yeah, that's Yeah, you've got Laura
Loomer, who's an extra from Saw. Then
you've got Mark Levin.
>> Then you've got Mark Levin, then you got
Ben Shapiro. These guys are clear-cut
>> They're misfits. Yeah, they're they're
they're the losers. You don't want to be
associated with those guys. Me and the
Ayatollah. So as we were saying, Mr.
Shean, Yeah. he wants to to rule it with
uh with the Ayatollah. Yeah.
He goes, "Maybe me." He goes, "So who's
going to who's going to take control of
the Strait of Hormuz?" Maybe me. Maybe.
Even then he's unsure.
AND THE AYATOLLAH
TRUMP AND AYATOLLAH SITTING IN the tree.
So now they're friends, are they?
Absolutely. I killed his father, didn't
he? So now he's going to make a deal
with his son.
And and you know what? All the experts
are saying, "Who's Trump been speaking
to? Is it just these Israelis with hand
puppets saying, 'Hello, Mr. Trump. You
want to do a deal with me?'" It's so
pathetic, you know, and we are It's not
the first time and it's not the last
time that we've seen something like
this. They say if you're ever feeling
useless, just remember America spent $2
trillion in Afghanistan against the
Taliban to replace them with the
Taliban. Yeah? There there was no
sharing of power. Here Trump's like at
least, Yeah. at least let's do a bit of
a, you know, It's me and the Ayatollah
going in.
Yeah, me and him we go way back, you
know.
>> you know what? To be honest, bro,
>> this.
Let's talk about the Suez Canal thing.
Mhm. Well, that that reshaped
international relations. Mhm. This
failed war, which is
going to be that. Mhm.
>> a failed war. It's going to reshape the
global order, bro. Mhm. Now it's like
it's not no longer like the American can
hegemonic power. It's going to become a
multipolar system. Mhm. It's going to be
the United States of America, Russia,
China. They're going to kind of have
even footing here a little bit, you
know.
And and people are talking about, "Okay,
well, you still got the so-called
petrodollar." Of course you got the
petrodollar. Yes, that is a is a power
that the Americans have.
But look how easily it can be disrupted.
Yeah. Look how easily that can be
disrupted.
>> what Iran did to disrupt the
petrodollar. Well, they they closed the
Strait of Hormuz for them. They closed
it and they said if you want to come
through, you you deal and you exchange
using the Chinese yuan. Mhm. And
suddenly Trump's
best friends with the Ayatollah because
not only was the economy going down, not
only because for US hegemony, the main
way they do that is by having military
bases worldwide. Yes, exactly. Now where
that was seen as a flex and as a
protection, now the Arab states are
realizing that this is actually a
liability, frankly. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Yeah, because we don't have the
infrastructure to to to kind of fight
against these attacks. America's not
helping us. Why the hell have we got
this useless base over here? That's
actually harming our own people and it's
actually removing the curtain that we
were able to hide these bases and a lot
of people didn't even realize it. Like,
huh? So many bases here in the Middle
East? So now the military bases are
under threat. The petrodollar is under
threat.
Petrol and the price of oil is going
sky-high. On top of that, Trump is most
likely going to lose the next election
because MAGA is finished.
>> had two terms anyway. He's had two terms
and that's it. Him and the Ayatollah,
remember? They're going to retire
together, get a cottage in the in in the
village somewhere. He might get
impeached, the man.
Or he might get shot.
As he should have THE FIRST TIME.
AND THEY TRIED TO BLAME IT ON THE
IRANIANS WHEN everybody knew it was the
Israelis flexing. So, bro, this is such
a failed pathetic war and it just goes
to show Israel is a liability, a
parasite. They themselves are, you know,
fine. Their reputation hasn't been shot.
However, it's the reputation of the
Americans that's been shot and they've
been embarrassed. In fact, I think the
whole thing can even be classed as a
humiliation ritual.
Yeah, just for Trump and America, they
just lost everything in this. They're
losing money, they're losing supporters,
they are losing everything, bro.
I think he might even lose Ivanka as
well.
He might have to live in Iran, bro.
Maybe with Hezbollah. Yeah, with the
Ayatollah, you know what I mean? He'll
take her.
Well, with that we will conclude.
And it's been hilarious Uh,
you know thing to watch.
Hilarious
this is better than the best stand up
comedy that we've seen in a while
frankly. It is it's actually hilarious.
It's funny. But we'll see what happens
next in sha Allah. May Allah protect the
people of Iran, the people of Palestine,
the people of Sudan and everywhere else
in the world, the people of Syria, Iraq
and everywhere in the world where there
is suffering. And may Allah destroy the
Zionist entity and its allies and also
its military. Wa salaam alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
You probably don't deserve to watch this
video. Your level is honestly too low to
watch this video. So feel free to click
away from the video. But for the few who
can handle responsibility, we're
building the only masjid in a village in
Norway. First payment is already done.
Final 500,000 remaining. Huge sadaqa
jariya waiting. If you're serious about
Islam, you'll pause the video and you'll
click the link below to donate right
now. If not, enjoy the comment section.